[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor
but with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish he'd get into some trouble
there's still time
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke and our
grandfather left us this creepy old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing well i
wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here
somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason
are you troubled by strange noises in
the middle of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
you guys hear that
something's coming
all city
it's like the walking dead
we're closed
[Music]
foreign